For more than a century physicists have tried to find a unified theory a
single mathematical framework capable of describing all of nature's forces
Albert Einstein who unified space and time in a special and general theories of relativity
Pursued this goal for over 30 years never succeeding today scientists are continuing the quest
Seeking to combine general relativity describing the universe on large scale stars and galaxies with quantum mechanics
describing the universe on subatomic scales
Each of these two theories works amazingly well in its own domain
But put them together like in the dense center of a black hole and the math falls apart
in the 1970s
Scientists came upon a potential solution, but from an unexpected starting point
Studies of nuclear processes in that era we were trying to understand the strong nuclear force
It's just the force that holds the nucleus of the atom
Together and that was a complete mystery how to do it in trying to solve that mystery
Physicists were led to a promising equation that seemed to describe
Vibrating strings that would hold together atomic constituents
but within just a few years a different theory proved to be the right solution for
Understanding the strong nuclear force and so strings no longer seemed necessary
Almost all of these several hundred people stopped working on
String theory at that time and only a handful of diehards continued to pursue them the few of us who continued working on string theory
Felt that the mathematics was so beautiful and compelling that this theory had to be good for something
Much like Einstein who spent long periods working on ideas outside the mainstream
Schwartz and his colleague Joelle shirk
Continued to explore string theory
We realized what string theory was good for and that was as a quantum theory of gravity at that point
I was convinced that this is what I would be worried to the rest of my career
Schwartz was proposing that string theory which had failed as a theory of the strong nuclear force was
Actually the solution to one of the biggest problems in all of physics
uniting gravity and quantum mechanics
When Schwartz excitedly announced this prospect few people paid any attention
The field just wasn't ready. So
Schwartz and a new convert Michael Green spent years developing the theory mostly on their own then in
1984 they achieved a breakthrough showing that the mathematics of string theory deftly avoided potentially lethal
Technical issues and this time the community of physicists heard them
Princeton between the University and the Institute for Advanced Study
You had almost half the experts in the world. Who were
working on related topics and I
Am told that at that point almost all of them dropped what they were doing and became string theorists as string theory rapidly progressed
There was a sense that research was but a few years away from uncovering the final and unified theory of physics
more than 30 years later the goal of a fully unified and thoroughly tested theory has yet to be achieved but
enthusiasm remains high
String theory has come closer than any other attempt to go beyond known physics and tackled the grand challenge of unification
But the question remains is string theory and elegant mathematical
Chimera, or our string theorist rapidly approaching the realization of einstein's dream